in general when it comes to debates the
person who wins is most often just like
more charismatic or a better
Communicator it's not necessarily the
person who's factually correct and you
might be a scientist with all the facts
on your side but you just might not be
good in a so-called debate format and
that is something that has to be
considered as well the answer to should
doctors and scientists debate
anti-vaxxers depends on a lot of things
it depends on what is the format how
serious or structured is the debate
who's in the audience what's the point
and what else could those doctors and
scientists be doing with their time as
usual these issues are not black and
white but I want to hear from you let me
know in a comment let me know in an
email what do you think about this core
question should medicine and science
debate anti-vaxxers or does it lend them
The credibility
and legitimacy that they should not be
given